[موسيقى]
هذه الآلات الفريدة من نوعها هي
من صنع ديفيد كلافين
وهو العقل المدبر وراء بعض
آلات البيانو غير التقليدية حقًا مثل هذه
الحفلة الموسيقية العمودية ، وهي أكبر بيانو في
العالم ،
قابلنا ديفيد في بلدة صغيرة في المجر
عندما صنعنا  فيلم قصير عنه
اليوم يدعونا إلى ورشة العمل الخاصة به
حيث يمكننا الجلوس والاستمتاع
بصوت كل واحدة من آلات البيانو الفريدة الخاصة به.
حسنًا ، تعال معي
هذا هو مسجل الحفلة الموسيقية
والمسجل يأتي من حقيقة أنه
يحتوي على سلسلة واحدة فقط  لاحظ أنه
يبلغ طوله مترين ودقيقتان
وخمس وعشرون
[موسيقى]
هذه واحدة من آلات البيانو الخاصة بي التي
استدعى مالكها مع الشخصية تكون
عمومًا أكثر نعومة ، وكل نغمة في حد ذاتها
واضحة دائمًا أنها لا يمكن أن تكون غير متناغمة
[موسيقى]
هذا هو أكبر بيانو لي ،
الحفلة الموسيقية العمودية الكبيرة التي يبلغ طولها 4 أمتار 70 ، وهي عبارة
عن أوتار مزدوجة لبيانو وحدة التحكم من أول
نغمة جهير لا يوجد بها أي بيانو آخر مما
يجعلها البيانو الأكمل
على الكوكب
[موسيقى]
ماي ماي  كان الدافع وراء إنشاء آلات البيانو
التي نبنيها اليوم هو أنني كنت
أتخيل صوتًا لم يكن
موجودًا كما اكتشفت خلال
حياتي بالعمل مع عازفي البيانو أنهم غير راضين أيضًا عن
آلات البيانو التقليدية التي
أحب تقديمها
أدوات الأشخاص لإنشاء موسيقى جديدة وجميلة
يحتاج العالم إلى أصوات مختلفة
أغانٍ أفضل أصوات أكثر في مجال البيانو
[موسيقى]